i do not like smooth jazz clap away keep
clapping
happy glorious monday everyone what a
great day to be alive
tyrus is finally back in studio
i can tell because there's a trail of
protein bar crumbs all the way to the
set
and lawrence kudlow won't come out of
his office
yeah he's still terrified he's terrified
of you
the downside is michael loftus is back
which means there's a homeless guy on
sixth avenue looking for his pants and
his underpants
but we'll still have a good show a great
show so let's start off with our
favorite climate warrior arnold
schwarzenegger remember the consequences
of global climate change are so pressing
the consequences of global climate
change are so pressing
seven million people are dying every
year because of pollution people are
suffering because they're living close
to freeway and the ports and there's
unbelievable pollution all of those
countries that come and give speeches
this we're not going to go and lose jobs
because if they're going green and also
they're liars
they oh they're just stupid and they
don't know how to do it that's 50 of my
missions since 1990 and that
really pisses me off
so
arnold wants to have a tremendous impact
on the environment and this weekend he
did
pumping iron how about pumping the
brakes buddy apparently arnold was
involved in a serious four-car pileup
this weekend as you can tell he was fine
apparently his pecs acted as his own
built-in airbags
but also he was driving the largest
vehicle you can find without a caboose a
gmc yukon
the kind that gets two-wheel revolutions
to the gallon the yukon's the only truck
larger than the place it's named after
if we're any more of a tank biden would
have left it for the taliban
now the car that crumpled underneath his
yukon like a housemaid under arnie
is a prius
the kind of car greenies like arnold
would love you to be driving while he
tools around in battle star galactica
but the fact is if you're in that yukon
you probably aren't going to go to the
hospital well unless it's for a
paternity test but if you're in the
prius hit by the yukon well just hope
you're wearing clean underwear you might
even be headed for the morgue or worse a
roll and jingle all the way too
it's an unfair match-up
i'm trying to think of ones that are
worse
that's just
i unfair know
what
anyway it wasn't captured on video but
here's a recreation and now gutfeld
reenactment theater presents crash de la
vista baby
[Music]
this has been gutfeld reenactment
theater
i can taste the emmy now i got now that
it gets big trucks they're safer more
comfortable and the things you can get
away with them with those tinted windows
just ask any cnn producer it's also got
plenty of room for out of wedlock child
seats but this is arnold who has been a
withering critic of those who don't
abide by the climate agenda he's pushing
for a world as natural as his
bodybuilding career wasn't
and if we don't do something now we were
all complicit i wonder if he mentioned
that to the fellas down at the car
dealership but you gotta hand it to him
he was a quick learner he was a
republican who stole the democrats game
plan that as long as you talk to good
game you could get away with anything as
long as you talk about climate you can
still fly in private jets you can still
sail on 100 million yachts you can fill
your hot tub with panda tears and tool
around brentwood in a vehicle that could
house mitt romney's entire family
yeah i bet they could fit all of them in
a yukon including the dog on the roof
there's a callback now i hope whoever
got injured fully recovers it's not
their fault they bought a car as sturdy
as a big wheel but the story provides a
lesson elites like to make rules for
other people so they don't have to abide
by them it's why people get into
politics the first thing you do after
introducing a law is violate it we get
the prius and they get the yukon whether
you're gavin newsom at the french
laundry or a police defunder hiding
behind armed security the whole point of
power is creating a world of exemptions
for yourself you can see it especially
in liberal bastions they're the ones
that love restrictions most because they
figured out how to live above and beyond
them either by working in politics or in
the media so in new york in la and dc
crime spirals out of control cops all
over the country being shot and killed
as innocent women are being randomly
murdered by deranged lunatics
but you still hear this
from the coddled fat bags at cnn these
are just some examples of the banners on
fox news in the past few days you get
the sense that america has gone to hell
declining quality of life america as a
apocalyptic hellscape that was one of
the actual banners
this is a narrative that's both
anti-biden it's also anti-democrats who
run urban areas and again it goes on and
on every hour i just wanted to give a
sampling by administration's a clown car
driving off a cliff it's a great example
of the kind of incendiary rhetoric that
you would have never seen from another
channel let's say during the trump years
or now during the bioneers
not true he sees this as an anti-biden
narrative no it's anti-crime
honestly how do you fit that much dumb
in one room even after they lose 90
percent of their viewers from last year
they continue with the same strategy
but at least brian's consistent we never
accuse him of waffling unless it's
topped with whipped cream and chocolate
sauce
yeah it's another fat joke here's why
because as crude and stupid as fat jokes
are no insult is worse than their bad
ideas they joked about violent crime
they actually laughed at the suffering
of victims
see you can fix fat but you can't fix
that
now stelter's lying of course when trump
was president we were screaming about
crime in portland seattle and new york
and elsewhere on every single show
meanwhile what was cnn doing
you listen to conservative media you
would think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner in new york city
tonight people actually walked up to us
and said thank you for i watch you every
night they're going to take your country
away and they're taking down the statues
and crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and they get
defunding police it's like
yeah talk about a car crash but i guess
when you have private security
surrounding you crime doesn't exist it's
just for the plebes but i get why cnn
has to lie it's the only news network
where take your daughter to work day has
to be done remotely and that could be
why cnn still exists if you can't
control your appetites control the news
to make sure you stay out of it and they
can't even get that right
she proves not every barefoot person
with a corncob pipe and a banjo is a
hillbilly fox business anchor tegan
mcdowell
he's got his own aisle at the salvation
army founder of theloftusparty.com
michael loftus
she communicates with the spirit world
mostly tequila rum gin and vodka fox
news contributor cat tip
and
he's like a cruise ship he's really big
and your grandma would love to be on him
my massive sidekick
and the nwa world television champion
it is true you get bobbed by the
grannies
they crawl all over you like they're you
know they're still the same age as mick
jagger so technically they are groupies
yes yeah
nice to be you're in my bucket list as
soon as i get my hip replaced it's
always
a thrill but you know thank you love
y'all thank you welcome back uh from
your uh sequestered life sabbatical
sabbatical yeah yes sabbatical uh so you
the monologue touched on crime it
touched on car accidents where would you
like to go i think
you once again phenomenal you always you
bring it you're never afraid but i think
at some point
someone has to tell you this stelter
thing has to stop yes okay because
you're literally the only reason why
he's on tv now
you are that 10 that's true that's
watching him you watch him thoroughly
and then you bring him on the show he's
literally a guest i'm about to get him a
little little chubby high chair right
here because you're all he's got yes so
his entire show is what can we do to get
it gut phil's attention so i thought
there's there's three reasons with you
guys it's either one you guys are
related somehow and you have to take
care of him how dare you two
he's got some really sketchy photos of
you from your young days or three he
bullied you when he worked here ah and
this is like you just gotta keep it
going showing you know success it's like
that the jilted lover that you know you
left behind but you want to let them
know how how much they're missing it
like i guess he could have been sitting
here if he hadn't played his cards right
he never worked
he never worked here wasn't he intern no
no no he was on red eye once okay that
kind of counts so
he was a guest one time
that was it that was it and he was quite
boring dagin uh schwarzenegger or cnn
take your pick uh schwarzenegger i do
love how he is trying to convey global
warming by sweating like he's going
through menopause like he really needs a
testosterone patch i wasn't looking at
you when i said that no it was just
arnold's still my hero i don't know what
he says he's never he's he's the last
one lou ferrigno and arnold's all i got
left no i'm about ready to throw down
about arnold because he's been so famous
for so long
this is the kind of garbage that you can
get away with where you are just a steam
in line sack of like schnitzel and you
can't even smell your own sanctimony and
you think about what he's gone through
in his life you mentioned so he had an
affair with the housekeeper who had a
kid and he was raising the kid like she
was bringing the kid along on family
functions to the house with his other
with his married family and the kid
looked just like him and he's like yeah
whose fault is that yeah i know but
whose fault is that it shows no the wife
put the goggles on no it shows major man
teats that he would do that that he
would try to get away who might have
done this it's not about the you know
what the thing is i i i you want to talk
about the car well yeah it's like a
prius would be a perfect car if
everybody else drove priuses but they
don't right they call you they should
call it the prius because in an accident
they're gonna have to pry us out of it
yeah i was just talking about
the jaws of life
yes
now i'm just talking about the
sanctimonious yeah yeah and you became
anti-trump yeah and then he he um
compares
january 6 to kristallnacht uh crazy that
is it because his dad's a nazi or was so
that just shows you again with the
climate change crowd it's
i'm going to lecture you about how you
should behave but i'm going to do this
because he's big and well formerly
famous but he thinks he can get away
barbarian yeah they're great
yeah
i like that true lies was a good film
and the one that happened on the orange
planet i can't remember what it was
called but uh total real recall that's
it hey good recall yeah i tried
jesus nailed it yes
it's like he's in the room yes
arnold can't do something good or noble
without an equal and opposite weird
thing happening yes like remember when
the lockdown started and he's like we're
all in this together and then the little
horse came in it's a donkey it's a
burrow it's a yes
we're not in this together i don't have
a little miniature horse getting out of
my hand about a good point and like like
the the wreck was fantastic that's a
good wreck because no one got hurt well
the whole woman had a prius man she was
a roller coaster she had a concussion oh
it's much worse it's
as as listen i guarantee as soon as she
saw arnold get out of the yukon she was
like oh everything that's emotional
trauma she just hit the lottery yeah
that's like the first phone call she
made was honey quit your job no arnold
was driving yes there must be nothing
better than getting hit by a celebrity
right well unless it's matthew broderick
then you're dead
yeah i almost got hit by britney spears
one time really yeah really yeah i went
into the ralph's grocery store she just
came flying by was she actually in a car
yeah okay
yeah this was right after the head
shaving bit
so hot yes it was cat uh last word to
you
would you like to talk about the
hypocrisy of the yukon versus the prius
or talk about how strange it is that cnn
is belittling people's concern about
crime
let's see
well i don't know i did like jingle all
the way yes uh but other than i did but
like sinbad was really good in it so i
don't know if i give him that much
credit yes but you know i it's obviously
i feel like if you really want to
convince people to care about climate
this is the worst thing you can do
because anybody who might be kind of on
the fence like yeah you know maybe the
earth does matter which i you know hot
take i think it does yes um
you don't just contradict yourself
because that's where you get people that
go hard against it because i mean that's
a massive vehicle and all it's all the
rich people that have the biggest carbon
footprints not to mention as you did say
getting your wife and housekeeper
pregnant at the same time
sounds like you conned us arnold
yes yes yes i did that i did that number
one name in late night news
right did you guys catch jesse's show oh
my god
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else